la tragédie turc avec une course contre
la montre qui s'est engagée pour
retrouver d'éventuels survivants 72
heures après le tremblement de terre les
chances s'amenuisent
mais il y a eu heureusement on va le
voir encore quelques miracles
marie-pierre compte elle a plusieurs
mais surtout garder son calme
pas de faux mouvement tout pourrait à
nouveau s'écrouler et sous cet amas de
béton
il y a encore une vie toute jeune cdes 9
ans est une miraculée elle vient de
passer 48 heures enfouis sous les
décombres
et elle s'en tire avec juste des
contusions sur le visage découvert ma
tête pour le protéger des pierres qui
tombaient il n'y a rien eu de grave a
part ça la grand-mère était à côté de
moi
elle va bien aussi elle est sauvée moi
je vais bien je ne suis pas blessé mais
autour de cds dont toute la région
il y à ce soir au moins 7000 victimes
ce chiffre ne cessera d'augmenter dans
les prochaines heures mais les
sauveteurs lutte contre ce souffle de
mort les français par exemple 150
pompiers et hommes de la sécurité civile
sont aujourd'hui à pied d'oeuvre en
turquie
des équipes comme celles ci arrivent du
monde entier au fil des heures de toute
l'europe mais aussi des états unis de
russie d'israël ou d'algérie
la banque mondiale va prêter un milliard
trois cents millions de francs à la
turquie l'aide afflue mais elle ne
pourra arrêter un terrible chronomètre
les chances de survie sous ces gravats
sans boire sans manger sont estimées à
72 heures
le séisme a eu lieu il y a trois jours